à mon cher Philippe Philippe la vie est
avec nous c'est un grand bonheur
Philippe fut ravie de te revoir cher ami
l'album on va en parler sous le même
soleil il vient de sortir on est très
heureux de t'accueillir alors tu vois
dès qu'on passe un petit peu de tes
morceaux de toi tu représentes le soleil
des Caraïbes il faut quand même le dire
la Martinique Fort-de-France où tu es
next alors les amis c'est vrai un peu
soleil quand il fait gris mais voilà
surtout en ce moment où il fait quand
même très beau sur la France mais tes
chansons
[Rires]
on va en parler avec ce nouvel album où
il y a de très très belles
participations également et puis en plus
tous les titres que nous aimons
d'ailleurs allez le préférez on va on va
le mettre que tu veux toi
je pensais que vous me demandez ma
chanson préférée c'est cholestéreuse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu vois tu vois
cette chanson avec Jocelyne
sympa c'est d'entendre quand on joue on
chante en province enfin quand on est
sur scène et qu'on chante là chanson les
gens parlent créole donc nous sommes en
train de la France les petits antillais
sont très le coloniser la France
complètement
le créole sera une langue c'est pas une
vraie langue bien l'an prochain monsieur
le ministre de l'Éducation a promis que
le créole serait dans toutes les écoles
l'année prochaine c'est unité c'est une
bonne suggestion mais c'est pas plein
d'y aller c'est ça on va lui dire voilà
mais je lui ai dit déjà tu lui as dit
déjà
ça promet alors on va écouter maintenant
l'amour en mer peut-être
[Applaudissements]
je sens qu'il y a une petite anecdote là
dessus non ça va une anecdote agréable
ou est-ce que tu veux
et
qui est venu mais alors c'est un mec
absolument charbon alors ça c'est dans
l'album voilà c'est dans le nouvel album
avec Claudio Capéo qu'on adore
évidemment ouais ouais moi j'aime bien
c'est toi qui l'a appelé comment ça
s'est passé on s'est croisé en fait on
s'est retrouvé à la Martinique l'an
dernier pour une émission de télévision
produit par euh bon tu vois et et
j'arrive à 10 heures du soir parce que
nous on avait voyagé dans un avion cargo
d'une compagnie aérienne qui dessert
beaucoup tu vois je fais pas de pub qui
dessert beaucoup les Antilles et fonce
dans l'avion alors
inutile de choisir quand on a débarqué
là-bas c'était un tout petit peu fatigué
avec modération
grâce à cette chanson et grâce du coup à
Philippe la ville j'ai une de mes plus
belles histoires amoureuses j'étais au
ski sur un télésiège au départ avec des
potes et une des copines vous connaissez
pas dire dont une que je pouvais très
jolie mais qui se désintéressait
complètement de moi et puis du coup
j'avais un peu lâché l'affaire comme ça
et en montant sur les pistes comme ça sa
copine est à côté de moi et elle me
parle de sa copine etc moi je croyais
attention me dit ça on s'en fout sa
chanson préférée c'est Philippe Lavil si
elle adore l'amour en mer je suis elle
me dit ça que j'en ai à [__] pour la
dernière je suis content pour elle
m'en ferait péter l'amour en mer dans ta
grand-mère mais c'était mais
ça et du coup bah après j'ai commencé
l'histoire d'amour
[Musique]
ce que j'aimerais en fait j'aimerais
entendre de nouveau ton premier titre
avec les filles je ne sais pas je
n'étais pas encore sûr de te lancer dans
la chanson avec une fille je ne sais pas
je ne sais pas
[Applaudissements]
très proche de votre vie
[Musique]
est-ce que je me trompe Philippe parce
que c'était c'est ton premier titre
celui-là la première chanson première
chanson beaucoup passée en radio qui
paraît-il à beaucoup beaucoup vendu je
suis pas sûr d'avoir tout vu mais bon
c'est une chanson alors c'était facile
de chanter ça quand on avait 20 ans à 22
ans je crois 75 c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué parce que tu es obligé
d'arriver avec des prescriptions
médicales tu vois Déborah
mais vous étiez quand même
je rêverais de savoir si c'est vrai ou
pas que le prince régnait en personne a
appelé votre maison disque pour demander
que ça cesse avec sa fille Caroline de
Monaco à l'époque avec qui vous aurez
une petite histoire alors qu'elle avait
rencontré Philippe de Hanovre
parce que moi je suis au courant aussi
simplement c'est une affirmation que je
ne connaissais pas
moi c'est très ami avec lui donc je ne
dirai rien je peux vous dire que
Philippe en tout cas super Playboy tu as
toujours eu cette image de Playboy de
beau gosse mais si le dandy
shit et toi
mais tu es toujours dans 10 chiffres
parce que je connais les chikungs mais
je connais pas
mon ami
faites des compliments vous lui crier
dessus
arrête de prendre les pastilles
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
on va calmer tout le monde
il tape il a dit non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Isabelle qui a une question qui brûle
les lèvres c'est quoi cette chanson sur
quel bambou tu pensais oh
c'est ce qu'elle m'a dit tout à l'heure
heureusement qu'il est là parce que ça
fait 40 ans que j'attends la question
[Rires]
dis-moi ce sont tous du bromure j'ai
l'impression
c'est dis-moi Philippe ce sont des
Caraïbes qui est tellement typique
d'abord de ce que tu fais de tes
origines et tout ça c'est un style ben
toujours c'est ça c'est
un instrument de musique qui a été
inventé à Trinidad
il y avait beaucoup de pétrole et il y a
un monsieur qui s'appelle Élie manette
qui a un jour coupé ça un flux de
pétrole en c'est ça en ferraille quoi il
a coupé en deux et puis avec des
marteaux il a commencé à mettre des
notes faire des notes alors c'était
toujours un petit peu bancal et là
maintenant il y a les ils ont
perfectionné l'histoire et non tu es fou
là ça reste très artisanal qui joue et
qui avec moi sur scène
qu'on voit tu sais avec tu tapes de
Céline Dion mais alors c'est formidable
si vous avez l'occasion un jour de
d'aller à Trinidad pendant carnaval il y
a des styles bandes à ce moment-là il y
a 40 personnes qui jouent et donc il y
en a qui sont devant qui avec les
guitares il y en a d'autres qui savent
ça s'appelle une guitare il y en a un
autre qui fait les deux les graves les
aigus les basses les trucs c'est
phénoménal on peut pas rester assis
c'est c'est un truc de fou et dis-moi je
crois quand même tout de même tes
parents n'étaient pas très favorable à
ce que tu chantes la chanteuse ou un
gamin bon chanteur chanter sur quoi ils
avaient peur que ça marche pas mon père
pensait que on pouvait chanter sous la
douche voir avec des potes mais que
c'était pas comme ça qu'on pouvait un
gagner sa vie mais voilà et puis un jour
il a senti que j'avais eu raison voilà
si tu as plus de 50 ans de carrière on
peut le dire bon cher ami 18 albums
cache rien cinq participants des séries
parce que tu fais aussi l'acteur deux
apparitions au cinéma et je sais que tu
étais un grand ami de Johnny Hallyday
aussi pas grand ami non parce que à
l'idée il avait pour moi il avait trois
ou quatre amis pas plus donc j'ai jamais
été un ami intime de Johnny Hallyday de
temps en temps on se voyait un petit peu
dans le Midi
et voilà c'est on oui chaque fois
j'allais dans son restaurant il avait
avec mon mon petit copain Claude
bouillon perdre ton âme mec et c'est
près des Champs-Élysées voilà et quand
il était seul parfois donc on partageait
un repas on parlait de choses et
d'autres quoi mais c'était
il m'a jamais fait de confidence quoi
voilà il adorait ta fille hein Lola je
crois il aimait bien parce que enfin il
aimait bien il aimait bien les enfants
il les a connu un petit peu et il jour
j'étais avec Lola et un de ses petits
copains de le son école je vous ai
emmené déjeuner au Balzac pour son
anniversaire et Claude bouillon était là
et arrive Johnny tout seul et Claude lui
dit tiens tu vois déjà dit Philippe est
là avec avec Lola c'est son anniversaire
aujourd'hui alors il l'embrasse il dit
tu vois Lola si j'avais su je t'aurais
acheté un cadeau j'ai pas de cadeau du
tout bon écoute je vous invite je vous
invite à déjeuner c'était pas obligé
non mais c'est vrai c'est un mec c'est
un mec énorme voilà il s'est un type
bienveillant c'était un type
incroyablement épouvantablement
attachant oui c'est vrai d'ailleurs Lola
qu'on retrouve aussi sur cet album
tu as eu du mal à convaincre ou celle
qui voulait y aller
elle a une très jolie voix mais c'était
pris plus
c'est la maison
qui te connaît
tu m'en âme souvent parler
[Musique]
c'est dans l'album sous le même soleil
le nouvel album de notre ami Philippe
Laville mais j'adore
déjà mis des casques quand tu faisais
des émissions de télé ou que tu
participes un peu importe quand on
entend savoir dans un casque c'est en
fait la voix que les gens entendent
alors que nous quand on parle on n'a pas
reconnais
ce casque et qu'elle a la première fois
j'ai envoyé les premières notes de bus
et puis finalement au bout d'une
demi-heure c'était qui battait et il a
fait deux prises et puis voilà c'était
fini tu sais quoi j'ai trouvé magnifique
je vais simplement mignon tellement
jolie
plusieurs fois de beaucoup d'eau dans
les yeux
c'est trop mignon vraiment vous le
trouvez dans l'album sous le même soleil
très content quand même que tu reviennes
comme ça la chanson tu l'as jamais
quitté mais là enfin un nouvel album ça
faisait un petit moment oui oui
des chansons qu'on a réarrangées bon ben
en fait oui
déjà on a envie on retrouve déjà tous
les succès on compte avec des inédits
vous avez composé récemment ou c'était
des titres que vous aviez
un peu à côté et ça nous a énormément
énormément
ce qu'on fait sur scène
la bossa nova comme ça le soleil les
voit un petit peu velours et tout c'est
toujours eu le son des Caraïbes avec lui
dans la série j'emballe facile
[Rires]
à partir
toujours un côté nonchalant limite
touriste qu'est-ce que ça est-ce que
c'est une nature est-ce que ça va pas un
peu des services desservies pour une
plus grande carrière au cinéma moi je
suis tenu compte et pas donné plus de
rôle dans les séries
ce côté j'ai pas faim un peu ah c'est
pas vrai parce que non c'est pas vrai il
y a j'ai un travers qui est énorme je ne
sais pas demandé
je ne sais pas demander une seule fois
j'ai demandé quelque chose à la à la
télé on me l'a accordé mais je n'ai
jamais cavalé après des gens pour dire
ils ont les potes mais moi sur ton film
ou machin truc jamais jamais jamais bon
en tout cas Philippe nous a parlé de
Johnny Hallyday juste avant maintenant
j'aimerais savoir pour Jean-Jacques
Goldman alors ah raconte-moi comment tu
as travaillé il a été
que je ne nommerai pas et qui dit oui
Philippe la ville il a refusé une
chanson à Jean-Jacques de Jean-Jacques
Goldman lui avait donné et qui
s'appelait elle a fait un bébé toute
seule mais j'étais en studio en train de
faire un album et
j'ai attendu avant de lui répondre quoi
et comme c'est ce que nous on restait
assez longtemps au studio et pour deux
mois et demi il m'a dit bon écoute je
récupère la chanson je vais la et je la
fais et c'était à lui il apprend il a
fait tu vois il m'a pas mais je vais pas
refusé une chanson
voilà et oui c'est ce que bon il faut
pas écouter toutes les rumeurs tu t'en
fous en fait je m'en fous et dis-moi tu
as travaillé en revanche avec Souchon ça
c'est sûr non j'ai alors tu vois ça
encore c'est ça c'est un texte de
dans une édition et j'ai dit à ce que je
peux faire une musique donc oui j'ai
fait une mélodie et quelques jours après
j'ai amené une cassette Alain l'a
entendu et il a donné son accord et
c'est une chanson qui était sur un album
en 78 qui s'appelle Tagada ne me dit
rien
à cette époque là le temps avance et
puis ça marche un peu moins et à un
moment vous vous écrivez la chanson il
tape sur des bambous euh je produis
juste et je chante
là ça devient numéro un des ventes vous
rendez je ne sais pas combien de
millions de disques
cette chanson vous vous disiez ça y est
j'arrête j'en ai marre j'avais déjà mon
billet d'avion pour la Martinique et
j'avais un allé simple et alors je
voyageais en première parce que après
tout voilà pas envie de croupir et puis
non mais le couper
[Rires]
le moral et on sauve des trucs quoi donc
voilà et puis on a fait cette chanson
elle est sortie et au bout de 15 jours
bobsoka m'appelle me dit Philippe garde
la bagnole garde la pape garde le tige
garde le sac etc tu vois ça paraît tu
restes à Paris et puis voilà je suis
resté à Paris
qui disent notamment je me souviens de
Florent Pagny s'il avait commencé son sa
carrière il aurait accepté de faire des
émissions comme Star Ac ou The Voice
parce que c'est un vrai booster est-ce
que vous quel regard vous avez sur ce
genre de démission est-ce que voilà
c'est vous auriez été tenté à l'époque
si ça avait on vous l'avait proposé
il faut il faut
je déteste juger
il faut prendre des parties à un certain
moment je suis trop faux cul pour me
permettre de faire ce truc
participant
je sais pas oui
à l'époque il y avait des radios
crochets mais nous non j'ai eu une autre
dont j'ai pas j'ai pas eu une attirance
pour ça Francesca moi je veux savoir
s'il va y avoir une tournée et vous
disiez que vous hésitiez à demander des
choses donc moi j'ai essuyé des refus
avec plein de stars dont je vous le
demande est-ce que vous cherchez une
choriste peut-être
tu veux nous quitter toi déjà non plus
le weekend
ah ouais c'est bien je trouve
pour l'instant j'ai pas besoin de
choristes
et puis dans l'album il y a aussi que de
capeo il y a aussi Victor Lazlo les
enfants et puis et puis et puis sa
précociste qui s'appelle personne ne la
connaît pour l'instant mais il s'appelle
Chloé Cassandre et je peux vous dire le
truc c'est que ça dégage le nouvel album
sous le même soleil Philippe Lavil de
retour dans
on écoute un extrait un extrait de La
Part des Anges
[Applaudissements]
le train filet vers la Provence je passe
du temps dans les nuages à m'implanter
des poils avant d'aller sans bagages aux
Antilles quoi d'autre
raison ils n'ont chalandise mais lorsque
je vagabondes sans laisser comme
l'argent
Philippe on adore vraiment bravo c'est
très heureux de t'accueillir mon cher
Philippe je tiens à dire tu seras le 21
juin à Caen et le 6 juillet au
Nuits-Saint-Georges pour l'instant on
commence comme ça et puis et puis voilà
essayer de se faire une année 2024 orge
olympiques